>>> JUST MINUTES AGO, NEWLY
ELECTED REPUBLAN CONGRESSMAN
GEORGE SANTOS WHO HAS BEEN UNDER
GROWING PRESSURE TO RESIGN AFTER
LYING ABOUT HIS JOB HISTORY, HIS
EDUCATION, HIS FAMILY HERITAGE,
SAID, AFTER SEVERAL DAYS SAYING
NO, HE SAID HE WOULD RESIGN
UNDER VERY SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> TOUF A RESPONSE FOR THOSE
CALLING FOR YOU TO RESIGN.
>> I WILL NOT RESIGN.
I WILL CONTINUE TO --
>> WHAT IS YOUR CALL -- IF THE
VOTERS ASK FOR YOU TO RESIGN.
>> I 142 PEOPLE ASKED FOR ME TO
RESIGN, I'LL RESIGN.
>> IN SPRESPONSE TO THAT, DON
BEYER IS SAYING WE COULD MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
AND NOT SURPRISING, MANU, I'VE
SEEN SOMEONE ON TWITTER STARTING
A PETITION.
BUT WHAT ARE REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS SAYING ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
>> THERE IS GROWING PRESSURE ON
HIM TO STEP ASIDE.
AFTER CONGRESSMAN SANTOS MADE
THOSE COMMENTS I CAUGHT HIM IN
THE BASEMENT WALKING BACK TO THE
CAPITOL AND I ASKED HIM ABOUT
HIS APPARENT WEB OF DECEIT ABOUT
HIS PAST AND EVERYTHING FROM
HAVING FAMILY THAT FLED THE
HOLOCAUST TO HIS PAST BACKGROUND
TO HIS EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND.
HE WON'T ANSWER ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS DESPITE PUTTING THAT
QUESTION TO HIM FOR MORE THAN A
MINUTE.
BUT YOU HAVE HEARING MEMBERS OF
HIS OWN DELEGATION, SOME
INCOMING MEMBERS SAYING HE
SIMPLY COULD NOT SERVE
EFFECTIVELY AND YOU LISTEN TO
THE CALL FROM BACK HOME TO STEP
ASIDE.
>> HE'S LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF
PEOPLE IN HIS OWN COMMUNITY.
SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK HE NEEDS
TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER WHETHER OR
NOT HE COULD ACTUALLY DO HIS JOB
EFFECTIVELY AND RIGHT NOW IT IS
PRETTY CLEAR HE CAN'T.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
WAY HE COULD POSSIBLY PERFORM
HIS DUTY BUT THE PAN HAS TO BE
HONEST WITH HIMSELF AND HIS
CONSTITUENTS AND IT IS CLEAR HE
CAN'T DO HIS JOB.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING HE SHOULD
RESIGN.
>> THERE IS NO WAY I THINK HE
COULD FULFILL HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES AND I THINK HE
NEEDS TO TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY.
>> BUT YOU DOES HAVE SUPPORT
FROM KEVIN McCARTHY.
SAYING IT IS UP TO THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE AND THAT IS SIGNIFICANT
GOING FORWARD.
McCARTHY IS SCHEDULED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN A MATTER OF
MINUTES.
UNLIKELY TO CHANGE HIS POSTURE
BECAUSE IF SANTOS WERE TO RESIGN
THIS COULD BE A PICKUP
OPPORTUNITY IN A SPECIAL
ELECTION AND THAT COULD TIGHTEN
THE MARGIN IN THE HOUSE IF
DEMOCRATS WITHER TO PICK THAT
UP.
>> IT IS ALL ABOUT THE NUMBERS.
THAT IS CERTAINLY THE GAME RIGHT
NOW.
MANU RAJU, APPRECIATE IT.
MICHAEL, LET'S LISTEN TO THE
SPEAKER.
MANU RAJU JUST MENTIONED KEVIN
McCARTHY.
REPUBLICANS ALWAYS SAY DEFER TO
LOCAL PEOPLE.
THAT'S OUR PHILOSOPHY, GET YOUR
INFORMATION.
THE LOCAL REPUBLICAN PARTY SAYS
HE'S GOT TO GO.
THE FELLOW NEW YORK FRESHMEN SAY
KEVIN McCARTHY NEEDS THAT VOTE,
SAYS NOT SO FAST.
>> HE'S GOT A LONG WAY TO GO TO
EARN TRUST.
BUT THE ONE THING I KNOW IS YOU
APPLY THE CONSTITUTION EQUAL TO
ALL AMERICANS.
THE VOTERS OF HIS DISTRICT HAVE
ELECTED HIM.
HE IS SEATED.
HE IS PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE.
THERE ARE CONCERNS, SO HE WILL
GO BEFORE ETHICS.
IF ANYTHING IS FOUND TO BE
WRONG, HE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> A QUICK HYPOCRISY POINT.
THE VOTERS OF AMERICA VOTED FOR
JOE BIDEN AND EVEN KEVIN
McCARTHY TRIED TO BLOCK HIS
TRANSITION TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT KEVIN McCARTHY AND HIS
POWER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, HE'S GOING TO
HOLD ONTO THAT VOTE AS LONG AS
HE CAN.
IT'S NOT A LONG WAY TO GO.
THE CLOCK IS TICKING.
AT MOST, IT'S TWO YEARS.
SANTOS' TALKING POINT IS 142,000
PEOPLE ELECTED ME.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
THERE IF THE WHOLE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT IS NOT WITH HIM.
SO HE'S NOT GOING TO WIN
RE-ELECTION, PLUS HE HAS SEVERAL
INVESTIGATIONS, AND THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS OUTSTANDING ARE WHERE
DID THE $700,000 LOAN THAT HE
MADE TO HIS CAMPAIGN COME FROM,
HE DIDN'T HAVE THAT REAL INCOME.
AND THERE'S ALSO QUESTIONS BEING
RAISED ABOUT A SEPARATE
FUNDRAISING EFFORT, A DONOR
SAYING I GAVE $25,000 TO THE
SUPER PAC BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE MONEY.
WHEN YOU COME TO ISSUES LIKE
STRAW DONATIONS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, THOSE ARE REAL CRIMES THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL GO
AFTER.
>> CRIMES THAT TAKE MONTHS AND
MONTHS TO DOCUMENT AND PROVE AND
THEN, IF THERE ARE CHARGES,
ADMINISTRATIVE CHARGES, THERE
ARE APPEALS PROCESSES.
THIS CAN GO ON FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
IS THAT McCARTHY'S END GOAL?
IF HE SURVIVES TWO YEARS, THEY
WILL RUN A PRIMARY CAMPAIGN
AGAINST HIM TO TRY TO KEEP THE
SEAT.
IS THAT McCARTHY'S GOAL, I NEED
TO KEEP THIS GUY AROUND, AS MUCH
AS IT STINKS?
>> IT'S SURE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, SANTOS
HAS PROVEN TO BE A RELIABLE
McCARTHY VOTE.
HE VOTED FOR McCARTHY FOR 15
ROUNDS DURING THE SPEAKERSHIP
RACE.
I THINK McCARTHY IS KIND OF
KEEPING SANTOS LOYAL BY SAYING
THESE THINGS ABOUT
REPRESENTATIVE SANTOS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF SANTOS
RESIGNS, THERE WOULD PROBABLY BE
A SPECIAL ELECTION THAT
DEMOCRATS WOULD TRY REALLY HARD
TO PICK UP THAT SEAT.
SO THE POLITICAL UPSIDES ARE FOR
McCARTHY TO KEEP SANTOS THERE,
BUT MAYBE KEEP HIM AT ARM'S
LENGTH, KEEP HIM IN A BUBBLE, SO
TO SPEAK.
THAT'S JUST THE POLITICS OF THE
SITUATION.
>> POWER OVER PRINCIPLE.
NOT THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SAID
THAT.
AND DEMOCRATS, I ASSUME AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THEY FEEL THIS WAY,
DEMOCRATS CERTAINLY LOVE IT.
THIS IS TED LU.
ARTICLE 1, SECTION 5 EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZES CONGRESS TO EXPEL A
MEMBER WITH A TWO-THIRDS VOTE.
ALLOW A FLOOR VOTE ON WHETHER TO
EXPEL GEORGE SANTOS.
THAT WOULD BE A RICH MOMENT
EARLY IN THE NEW REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY.
NUMBER ONE, THEY THINK THE FACTS
ARE ON THEIR SIDE, BUT THAT
WOULD BE A RICH POLITICAL
MOMENT.
>> AND REALLY THIS IS ALL
CREATING SO MUCH OF A
DISTRACTION FOR WHAT REPUBLICANS
ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO AS
THEY TAKE OVER CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OR OTHER FIGHTS
THEY'VE BEEN TEEING UP.
NOW THERE'S SO MUCH ENERGY AND
THE GEORGE SANTOS STORY IS
SUCKING ALL THE OXYGEN OUT OF
THE ROOM.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY HAVE AN INFLUENCE ON
KEVIN McCARTHY.
BUT I THINK HAS EVERYONE HAS
SAID, HE WANTS TO KEEP CONTROL
AND THAT NEW YORK SEAT IS GOING
TO BE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S GOING TO SIDE
WITH SANTOS.
>> SO YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
LISTEN TO RANK-AND-FILE
REPUBLICANS AND THEY THINK THIS
IS HORRIBLE, WE'RE EMBRACING A
LIAR.
IN THE AGE OF TRUMP, MAYBE
THAT'S LESS OF AN ISSUE THAN I
THINK IT IS, HISTORY MIGHT THINK
IT IS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OBTAINED
GEORGE SANTOS' RESUMÉ AND I'M
GOING TO GO THROUGH TWO PAGES.
YOU CAN FIND THIS ONLINE.
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH IN HERE
WHERE HE SAID HE WORKED FOR
COMPANIES THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
HE DIDN'T WORK THERE.
BUT THE RICH PART HERE, I WAS
JOKING WITH THESE GUYS BEFORE WE
CAME ON THE AIR, WE WENT AROUND
THE TABLE AND ASKED EVERYONE
THEIR GPA.
GEORGE SANTOS CLAIMED HE HAD A
3.89 GPA AT A COLLEGE HE DIDN'T
ATTEND.
>> THE RESUMÉ LEAVES OUT THAT HE
WAS A STAR VOLLEYBALL STRIKER,
WHICH ALSO WASN'T TRUE, WHICH HE
TOLD SOMEBODY AT A PARTY.
IT'S, I THINK, PATHOLOGICAL WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
IT'S NOT JUST SOMEONE WHO
EMBELLISHED THEIR RESUMÉ.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO HAS LIVED
THEIR LIFE SORT OF AS A CONMAN
AND FINALLY GOT THE BRASS RING.
>> IS THERE A TIPPING POINT FOR
McCARTHY?
I GET THE RAW POLITICS OF THIS,
I GET THE NARROW MARGIN.
I GET THE MATH OF WHY KEVIN
McCARTHY WOULD WANT TO KEEP
GEORGE SANTOS AROUND AS LONG AS
HE CAN.
HE MADE A WHOLE LOT OF
CONCESSIONS SAYING, WE HAVE A
BIG TENT, WE'RE GOING TO LISTEN
TO EVERYBODY.
DOES THIS GET TO A POINT WHERE
IF ENOUGH RANK-AND-FILE SAY WE
CAN'T DO THIS?
>> I THINK THE TIPPING POINT
USUALLY COMES FROM THE PEOPLE,
WHEN THE VOTERS AT HOME START
LEANING ON THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND SAYING YOU'RE SUPPORTING A
GUY WHO IS A LIAR AND A FRAUD
AND WE DON'T LIKE IT, AND THEN
THOSE ELECTED OFFICIALS START
LEANING ON KEVIN McCARTHY TO
SAY, HEY, WE'RE GOING BACK HOME
AND WE'RE GETTING YELLED AT IN
THE GROCERY STORE AND OUR PEOPLE
ARE SAYING, WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
DOING IN WASHINGTON?
THAT CREATES THE TIPPING POINT.
UNTIL THAT GROUND SWELL HAPPENS,
I DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE MUCH IN
WASHINGTON.